what's up guys marquez here
first of all
i've wrestled with like what to even say
about any of all of this i mean there's
so much going on right now
the global pandemic of course um the
chaos and leadership in this country
and of course the the protests going on
about police brutality against black
people in america it's a lot
um i was inspired
to at least share this by neil degrasse
tyson and his post of the same name so
i'll link it below go read it it's
really good it's thoughtful and it sheds
a lot of light on his experience
um
i read it because i was curious about
his experience and
i feel like uh it inspired me to share
my experience just because it might be
useful for the same reason so first of
all
i'm a tech youtuber i make videos about
tech i've been doing this since i was 15
years old so like
you know in the the bedroom of my
parents house and i've been lucky enough
to be able to turn this thing that i
love to do
into a job but of course as i've done
this and as i've built this for the past
decade plus it's come with all sorts of
unintentional
consequences and and new things that go
with it whether it's
hiring decisions or management decisions
or ethics questions just a whole bunch
of other things come with being able to
make that your job but also if we just
rewind the clock back before
you know before i even started any of
this before the videos and all that
stuff
i've been lucky enough to have amazing
parents that
supported me and encouraged me to try
new things and experiment to find the
things i like
and then would support when i would
latch onto things and for me
none of these things
started
with anything to do with the color of my
skin it was it was luckily literally
just things i was super interested in
and
the longer i'd stayed in these things
and the more i'd got rooted in these
communities and these activities
the more it would start to come up so
for context i've been an avid golfer
since i was 10 years old uh i've been an
ultimate frisbee player since before
high school at a professional and club
level and i'm a tech youtuber i make
videos so it was
it was an escape basically
to be able to bury myself in my work
and these activities
as a way to like isolate myself from
all the rest of what was going on around
the world because at the end of the day
as soon as it's over as soon as i leave
as soon as i drive home
as soon as i'm driving it snaps you back
to reality where like you could be
pulled over
for nothing basically or because we
don't see that type of car around here
or just anything stupid that would sort
of bring you back to that frustrated
place i have stories about encounters
with the police my friends have stories
but at the same time i have police
officers in my family and i know police
officers who are also frustrated with
all the same stuff that's going on but
the point is
things are different
first of all i'm not a 15 year old
anymore i'm an adult
and
second i have this platform now where
you know and there are plenty of others
like me that also have a platform where
they can share and express support for
what they believe in and and whether
it's these issues or any issues that
pertain to what they believe in and with
that there's always the the staying your
lane
stick to tech people you always see that
where it's like okay
i get it like i always say my first rule
is when picking a role model
i have a very narrow definition of what
i look up to someone for and it's for
what they're good at so when i was
playing golf for example i looked up to
tiger woods
the golfer you know and i looked up to
kobe bryant the competitor but it gets
to a certain point where
silence
or just where
we're not speaking up for the issues
that are plaguing
our community
feels worse i'd rather speak up but
here's another
point of reflection
so being able to bear myself in my work
you know as competitive as i am trying
to to be the best at something or just
get better at something
that by itself was
almost enough of a distraction
to forget that i am usually the only
black person in the room almost enough
but not completely you know you can
probably imagine my parents as i'm
growing up but they're learning like oh
he likes golf all right sweet and then
finding these really nice diverse golf
camps renaissance junior golf shout out
to them i loved going there every single
time
um or learning you know he likes
ultimate frisbee all right cool great
the school has a team
and that by itself i recognize is a
privilege in itself that not everybody
has but slowly you know things change
and slowly you get to this this place
where
at a high level golf
doesn't have much diversity you know at
a high level ultimate frisbee is not
very diverse
at a high level
tech
is not very diverse
so the spotlight sort of reappears on
the color of your skin and i realized
that i'd kind of basically shied away
from this
spotlight
too even though it's a good spotlight
like i was proud of it i can and it was
something to wear with pride
but at the same time it was like weirdly
in the way where you could never just be
one of the better frisbee players you
would be
the good black frisbee player you
instead of just being
one of the best black creators i wanted
to be one of the best
creators period so it's just just this
weird conflicting place where
you want to be proud of it but also be
able to be alongside it at the same time
you know i remember like several
instances where i would like accomplish
a goal or i'd make a high-end team
and i was super proud of it but then i
would like that spotlight would appear
again and i'd start to
second-guess that where i'm like did i
make this team
because i'm good enough
or did i make this team because they you
know i have this platform and they want
to take advantage of that or did i make
it this team because i'm black
and they just want to make sure they
have a black person and i'm looking
around like well they got one but
you know suddenly i'm second guessing
myself like am i
am i good enough to make this team
i don't know but i think at least for me
understanding
that i put that mental hurdle in my own
head that that's something worth sharing
that's not something
everybody has to think about but here's
the bottom line here's here's the
message i posted something a couple days
ago about how everyone
uses their voice and and their potential
platform differently some people
silently donate and work behind the
scenes some people use their voice and
their platform to inspire change but i
want to use this platform i have
right now in this moment for two things
one
to share the message that
not only is racism obviously
unacceptable but we actually have to
actively work against it and there's
always somehow people like twisting that
making it political making it like a
two-sided thing i don't understand how
being anti-racist can possibly be
controversial in any way and if it is
for you
then you should probably leave i have no
problem with losing racist followers
that's fine
that's something i take a stand on but
number two i want to try to be
something to look up to
for kids like the 15 year old me
you know to kids that
want to be able to look at a high level
of something
and see someone that looks like them
making the right choices and finding
success
that's what i want to try to be you know
i don't i try not to ask for too much
like i've had people
really nice people reaching out like you
know seeing what's going on in the world
like what can i do to help reaching out
and it's great that they're thinking
that way and that's positive but i'm not
the one that needs help it's the
organizations that are out there on the
front lines and that are supporting the
cause that need your donations right now
so i'll leave a link below specifically
if you want to help in that way but
here's something i will ask and
something that's in my world that i can
actually speak to there's a lot of
threads going around about
finding black creators and just
following them supporting them
and that's that's great that's really
positive but make sure you follow them
and support them because you actually
really like what they do some people
might not know this and i don't even
know if youtube would ever say it but
finding and subscribing to a new youtube
channel and then not engaging and
interacting with their content
actually sends a bad signal to youtube's
algorithms where if you just subscribe
to a channel and never watch their stuff
then youtube takes that as a flag that
this stuff isn't interesting and then
makes it harder for that stuff to
surface so you know flooding a channel
with the numbers is a nice look but it
can actually bury that channel so what
i'm asking is find a diverse group of
creators
and actually get into and enjoy what
they're making the actual creation
itself and why they're a creator that's
the best part of it i'm gonna link some
of my favorites below i encourage you
guys if you have suggestions to link
those in the comments down below and
then if you want go through those and
look through and find some of your
favorite new creators that you can find
and support in this way the ones i'm
gonna link below are both people in tech
that i've met from this awesome job and
that do great stuff and also just others
that i've also watched and enjoyed so
hopefully you can go through those and
find stuff too but look at the end of
the day there's no there are no easy
answers everyone has a different
struggle
everyone has different experiences
hopefully my reflections can be useful
to someone just looking to understand
better
but just know that this whole social
media thing can make it feel like a very
now thing like it feels feels like a
very 20 20 thing this is very now thing
maybe that's because the short attention
span of the internet but
this is of this is an ongoing thing this
has been a thing
and this will continue to be a thing
we have to spread the message we have to
be responsible and use our voices
and we have to move the needle thanks
for listening
and i'll catch you guys in the next tech
video
peace